bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour un nouvel épisode sur la
modernité avec une vidéo où l'on va
traiter de la pollution et des déchets
alors cette vidéo elle n'était pas prévu
à la base en mai publication c'est
pourquoi son format va être un petit peu
différent de ce qui se passe
habituellement sur la chaîne
qu'est ce qui alors motivé cette vidéo
qui n'était pas prévu au départ
eh bien j'ai participé cet été à un
événement qui était une tournée de pique
nique zéro déchets organisée par
laetitia de la chaîne le corps la maison
l'esprit si vous ne connaissez pas
laetitia je vous ai mis dans la barre
d'infos sous la vidéo un lien vers son
travail ses pique-niques ça a été
l'occasion de faire se rencontrer autour
d'un repas des personnes sensibilisées
ou non aux questions liées à l'écologie
au traitement des déchets et aux
alternatives aux plastiques et aux
produits chimiques qui encombrent notre
quotidien ça a été aussi un énorme et
prétexte pour manger manger manger et
toujours mangé j'ai été invité à
participer au pique nique et à mettre en
place un atelier
j'ai donc réalisé un micro-trottoir avec
les personnes sur place en les
questionnant sur leur vision de la
pollution et des déchets la première
question que j'ai posée et que je vous
pose également ici et quelle image vous
vient spontanément lorsque vous entendez
les mots pollution déchets moi je vois
un bord de plage avec des phoques avec
des poissons des oiseaux
christian a échoué sur la plage j'ai vu
du plastique enfin j'ai vu un gobelet en
plastique
voilà l'image qui me vient c'est fameux
7e continent voilà moi la première image
c'est moi la terre abîmé quoi - fonds de
poubelle une bouteille qui se baladent
dans l'armure fidh a pas la poubelle les
détritus radioactifs
ok sac plastique le plastique on a
souvent l'impression en effet que la
pollution et celles liées aux plastiques
et aux dérivés pétrochimiques et qu'il
s'agit donc d'un faits récents mais la
pollution est elle propre à notre époque
est elle si récente que ça donc c'est
pas du tout quelque chose de récent soit
je pense pas c'est plus à l'ère
industrielle du 19e siècle sont à mon
sens ces récents bref ça va servir du
modernisme là on a commencé à tout
emballé
quand on a inventé le plastique sans
vraiment et ça commençait de la sa date
je pense du 20e siècle
deuxième partie du xxe siècle plutôt
incertain dix huitième voire avant voilà
je suis pas ses qualités dans cet
épisode je vais m'attacher à vous
montrer que la pollution n'est pas un
fait moderne qu'elle n'est pas seulement
propre à notre époque et que les déchets
ne sont pas si inutile qu'on le dit
alors petite parenthèse en aucun cas
dans cet épisode vous verrez par la
suite je ne fais l'apologie des déchets
je suis la première à râler lorsque je
vois quelqu'un qui laisse tomber
involontairement quelque chose par terre
ici on va s'intéresser à la notion du
déchet en utilisant comme base de
réflexion
les témoignages recueillis lors des
micro trottoirs et la littérature
scientifique
une dernière précision cet épisode ne
t'en absolument pas à examiner la
question du traitement des déchets de
façon exhaustive j'ai simplement
sélectionner des exemples de pollution
qui me paraissait intéressant d'aborder
ici
l'homme a toujours pollué depuis la
maîtrise du feu laissant une couche de
suie sur la paroi des grottes si on veut
être tout à fait précis
alors évidemment là on est dans l'ordre
de l'anecdotique c'est pourquoi on va se
pencher sur une autre période qui est
l'antiquité grecque et romaine et
particulièrement le 1er siècle après
jésus-christ dès cette époque les grecs
et les romains dont nous sommes les
héritiers en quelque sorte ont pollué à
grande échelle
et quand je dis à grande échelle c'est
réellement le cas puisqu'on parle ici de
pollution atmosphérique la première
pollution dont j'aimerais vous parler
c'est celle au plomb dont usa je suis
très très important au cours du 1er
siècle par les romains alors pourquoi le
plomb très tôt les hommes comprennent
que le plomb est malléable à très faible
température et que ça permet donc de
créer des canalisations courbes et ça
pour les romains c'est hyper pratique
pour leur réseau de canalisations à rome
et pour les canalisations dans les
termes les bains publics dont les
romains raffolent aujourd'hui on sait
que l'absorption du plomb constitue un
risque majeur de santé publique
une intoxication aiguë ou chronique
provoque des cas de saturnisme
les romains n'avaient pas conscience de
cette menace et dans d'anciennes
publications scientifiques vous pourrez
lire que cette intoxication au plomb a
pu être la cause de la chute de l'empiré
romain
aujourd'hui cette thèse elle est réfutée
néanmoins des études récentes révèlent
que déjà au premier siècle de notre ère
les eaux du tibre le fleuve qui passe
par hommes étaient déjà fortement
pollués au plomb et que l'eau du robinet
de la rome antique contenait jusqu'à 100
fois plus de plomb que les eaux des
sources locales
ce qui nous permet quand même
d'envisager que le plomb a certainement
engendrer un problème de santé publique
à cette époque j'ai parlé d'études
scientifiques ok mais concrètement ou
voit-on et comment voit-on les
pollutions anciennes aujourd'hui cette
pollution au plomb ont l'adsl dans les
argiles et les limons c'est à dire les
couche supérieure du sol notamment dans
le port antique de rome pour tous à
austin on a notamment étudié les bassins
de claude et de trajan qui date du 1er
et du 2ème siècle de notre ère une autre
pollution c'est celle au cuivre toujours
par les grecs et les romains et que l'on
voit très bien au groenland
il faut savoir qu'au groenland ont
effectué des carottages c'est à dire
qu'on creuse très profondément et on
sort un tube de glace composé de
matières organiques que l'on étudie des
recherches se sont établies à subite en
1990 et 1992 il est apparu que les grecs
et les romains avaient déjà polluée à
grande échelle
l'atmosphère de l'hémisphère nord près
de deux mille ans avant la révolution
industrielle
car durant ce 1er siècle les romains ont
produit accrochez vous bien
quinze mille tonnes de cuivre par an on
voit à présent que la pollution n'est
pas propre à notre époque et surtout
qu'elle existait avant la révolution
industrielle
si nous avons un gros problème avec le
plastique aujourd'hui au moins nous en
avons pleinement conscience ce qui
n'était peut-être pas le cas pour les
populations avant faut bien l'admettre
nous avons une vision péjorative du
déchets jetés c'est mal
les déchets faut éviter dans le
vocabulaire le terme déchets vient du
latin immune douce ce qui a donné au
monde east c'est-à-dire un objet nom
propre que l'on associe à la puanteur et
à l'impureté aujourd'hui dans notre
langage
un déchet c'est un objet inutilisable
agressive et ou polluants et qui surtout
n'est pas à sa place et qui engendre
donc une pollution visuelle
pour moi la pollution c'est un petit peu
tout le surplus qui s'accumulent et qui
va en perdition mais ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que sans déchet on ne
connaîtrait pas l'histoire des hommes
et oui sans déchet je n'aurais pas pu
vous raconter tout ce que je vous ai
raconté sur les grecs et les romains
quand on étudie l'homme et bien on
étudie ces déchets pas que évidemment il
ya aussi les productions artistiques par
exemple mais il faut bien l'admettre les
audio constitue une trace de nos vies de
nos activités et de nos technologies
d'où l'expression laisser sa trace et
pour ça les romains ils ont bien réussi
leur pari
le déchet c'est donc un mal anciens qui
est aujourd'hui devenue insupportable
parlons un peu du plastique puisque
c'est notre problème ce problème
survient au moment où les déchets
organiques compostables sont remplacés
par des déchets imputrescible polluants
encombrant pour illustrer le problème du
plastique je vais vous parler d'un
dernier cas cette fois actuelle qui est
l'exemple de mayotte île des comores
département français peut-être que
certains d'entre vous ils sont allés en
tant que touristes et peut-être que vous
aurez pu remarquer les tas de déchets un
petit peu partout dans les rues
toujours toujours des déchets je parle
de mayotte parce que j'ai des
témoignages que j'ai reçus de la part de
proches qui ont vécu là bas et aussi
parce que c'est un département français
donc anciennes colonies et c'est là que
c'est intéressant vous avez voix en tant
que touriste on a précisé venant ici
d'un pays dit développés vous aurez
peut-être tendance à dire c'est galère
j'ai beaucoup écouté ses conseils ce qui
peut se comprendre
et puis peut-être qu'au bout d'un moment
une autre idée sous jacente va arriver
et on pourrait la traduire comme ça à
mes ces gens sont des gros dégueulasse
ça par contre c'est moins devraient en
tout cas c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça en a l'air
on pourrait alors se poser une question
toute simple pourquoi les mahorais
polluent pourquoi les mort et jettent
ils leurs déchets à l'air libre
à cette question on me répond par un
fait historique
les mahorais jette parce qu'ils ont
toujours rejeté je m'explique avant
l'arrivée en masse du plastique ces
populations produisait des déchets
organiques puisqu'il vivait
essentiellement de la pêche des cultures
des fruits lorsque les occidentaux sont
arrivés avec les nouveaux objets en
plastique une nouvelle alimentation
surtout à partir des années 50
eh bien ces populations sont passés du
tout organique ça ne fait rien de jeter
puisque c'est compostables au tout
plastique
évidemment les explications quant au
traitement de cette matière plastique
à l'époque elles ont été certainement
assez faible puisque on a eu pas
énormément de recul sur cette matière au
final les différences d'attitude face
aux déchets sont devenus des habitudes
culturelles
je pensais pas les gens qui feint citer
les gens qui sont responsables mais
c'est parce qu'on leur a dit bah tiens
maintenant tu vas manger comme ça et tu
vas voir ta l'état les habitudes et du
coup maintenant à nous de se
responsabiliser
mais tard avec l'exemple de mayotte on
s'est rendu compte qu imposer un nouveau
mode de vie avait eu des répercussion
néfastes et n'avait fait que renforcer
l'opposition nature et culture les
anthropologues le savent
la coupure nature culture en dit
beaucoup sur le lien qu'entretient un
individu avec son environnement
on pourrait également évoquer l'aspect
psychologique ou les individus y est
rare cheese leurs besoins cette unité
soutenu par abraham maslow avec sa
pyramide des besoins
en effet on peut tout à fait concevoir
que les préoccupations d'une personne
pauvre seront davantage centré sur
l'accès à la nourriture à l'eau potable
et un toit et que les préoccupations
écologiques apparaîtront un second plan
tandis qu'un individu riche en tout cas
qu'ils ne s'inquiètent pas quant à sa
survie sera plus disponible pour
réfléchir aux questions écologiques
encore une fois cette théorie elle est
très discutée mais j'ai trouvé
intéressant de la mentionner ici
durant ces pique-niques zéro déchet j'ai
pu rencontrer beaucoup de personnes qui
avaient adopté un régime alimentaire
particulier que ce soit végétarien
végétalien crudivore et j'en passe le
choix d'un mode de vie que certains ont
bien voulu m'expliquer souvent on
devient vegan par rapport à la cause
animale ou pour
pour une question de santé et c'est vrai
que l'approché écologique elle vient
plus après troisième peut-être un
quatrième raison mais personnellement
c'est vraiment la raison majeure pour
laquelle je laissais dernière mégane et
divisionnisme ça se sent rejoint un peu
l'écologie compagnie donc 02 succédera
ça permet de limiter les émissions à
effet de serre et ça permet
condé dont il était la position on
remarque tout de suite que ces régimes
alimentaires sont en lien avec une
démarche écologique très forte et que ce
n'est absolument pas un moyen d'être
plus beau plus mince plus musclée j'ai
enfin pu leur demander s'ils avaient
déjà tenté d'imposer ou de convaincre
quelqu'un de leur entourage à ce mode de
vie c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué d'expliquer à tout un mode de
vie en plus quand on n'a pas fait et
tous cheminer le long des différentes
étapes
en fait on a l'impression que c'est
vraiment une montagne je pense qu'on
peut les convaincre mais pas en leur
parlant directement du régime
alimentaire mais plus en abordant les
points sensibles c'est à dire la
pollution la cause animale ou la santé
je pense que des gens ils font ce qu'ils
veulent et sont vraiment libres de faire
ce qu'ils veulent et ça pour moi c'est
très important d'être vraiment conscient
de ses choix savoir pourquoi on le fait
mais pas pour faire plaisir parce qu
elle c'est une mode dont parce que c est
bien vu que ce soit à grande échelle
comme le cas de mayotte ou à une échelle
beaucoup plus intime le cadre familial
lorsque l'on impose son mode de vie que
l'on arrive avec une nouvelle façon de
faire en énonçant simplement que c'est à
présent la marche à suivre
on peut rarement espérer avoir des
résultats positifs et le meilleur moyen
de faire une personne identifiable
causes restent encore le faire ensemble
l'exemple concret la démonstration
c'est pourquoi cette initiative des
pique niques est une réussite selon moi
faire se rassembler des individus de
tous les âges de toutes les origines de
tous les régimes alimentaires autour
d'un repas a été je pense une source
d'inspiration pour beaucoup de joie et
de partage
et est ce qui a le plus joué je pense
que c'est les ateliers c'est clairement
les bateliers a permis l'achat de
d'assimiler plus de connaissances et de
repartir en se disant massa je peux
l'utiliser de telle façon mal et je
pense que pour beaucoup d'entre nous ça
a même été un soulagement de pouvoir
vérifier que nous n'étions pas seuls à
nous poser des questions sur nos modes
de vie modernes et aux problèmes qu'ils
engendrent la position à adopter face
aux déchets seraient peut-être la
suivante agir individuellement pour la
collectivité ce n'est pas parce que vous
ne voyez pas l'impact de votre geste que
celui ci ne compte pas
mission je dis non à la fille george
bush j'ai connu aulas
j'espère que c'est ça son nom à mais
c'est dégueulasse ici